[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de libre-échange
sur Public Sénat 30 minutes de
conversation avec les grands acteurs de
l'économie française votre invité
aujourd'hui à le syndicalisme chevillé
au corps il ne porte jamais au grand
jamais de cravate même quand il va
l'Elysée il aime le foot même si
certains trouvent qu'il ne jouent pas
assez collectif il pratique le
franc-parler il verrait d'un bon œil une
femme lui succédé il a combattu dans la
rue les lois el khomri les ordonnances
penico et la réforme ferroviaire sans
pour autant les empêcher la réforme des
retraites est son dernier combat à la
tête de la plus ancienne organisation
syndicale de France bonjour Philippe
Martinez bonjour merci d'être là
secrétaire général de la CGT
le portrait la youva ou pas
oui on fait rapide évidemment oui oui et
puis il y a quelques trucs je jouais
perso j'ai jamais perso moi je veux
toujours collectif toujours numéro 10
sur le terrain c'est vrai ça non non pas
enfin en vieillissant parce qu'on court
moins et on reste dans le rond central
mais j'ai joué arrière
à tous les postes ou il manquait
quelqu'un en fait la réforme des
retraites films Martinez est-ce que
c'est l'occasion pour la CGT de
reprendre la main de montrer qu'elle
peut gagner des combats puisque je l'ai
dit
à la fois sur Pénicaud et ordonnances
Pénicaud les lois el khomri vous n'avez
pas pu inverser le cours de l'histoire
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un enjeu
que pour les organisations syndicales et
pour la CGT c'est un enjeu pour les
citoyens parce que un syndicat tout seul
sans adhérents sans participation du
monde du travail enfin des citoyens
général ça ça sert à rien donc c'est un
enjeu de société cette histoire de de
réforme des retraites et c'est savoir si
on passe du temps à vivre après le
travail ou si on va directement du
travail au cimetière on peut résumer ça
comme ça après quand on va ce qu'on fait
d'autres pays confrontés à cette
démographie vieillissante tous autour de
nous je parle pas de pays exotique mais
le pays limitrophes l'Espagne
la Belgique l'Allemagne tous ont
reportés l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite 65 67 ans c'est qu'à priori il
y a une solution logique qui s'impose et
pourquoi la France restera à l'écart
justement de cette question de ce
problème démographique le vieillissement
premièrement je crois pas qu'on puisse
comparer même les pays européens entre
eux vous l'avez dit certains pays la
démocratie et pas la même l'âge de la
population et pas tout à fait le même
regardez en Allemagne d'ailleurs c'était
très bien ils ont accepté plus
volontiers les immigrés les réfugiés que
chez nous donc on peut pas tout comparer
et puis
moi je croise des organisations
syndicales des responsables syndicaux
d'autres pays
qui
se disent aussi on travaille trop
longtemps dans notre pays on travaille
trop en général si on veut laisser de la
place aux jeunes donc
je et puis il faut que la France a
toujours une originalité par exemple la
sécurité sociale c'est une originalité
française solidaire et et dans la
retraite telle que nous la connaissons
aujourd'hui en France il y a plein de
points positifs qui aimeraient bien
avoir mes homologues syndicaux parce que
entre le gouvernement évidemment les
objectifs sont parfois différents ceux
qui disent notamment gouvernement que si
on ne fait rien le système va dans le
mur et que
on va vers la feuille du système c'est
excessif c'est faux c'est faux c'est
faux
non c'est faux c'est faux en tout cas
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est faire des
choses mais pour l'améliorer pas pour le
dénaturer oui il faut régler
l'amélioration des pensions oui mais
mois à 1200 euros parce que personne
peut vivre avec 1200 euros il y a que
ceux qui vivent avec des millions qui
considèrent que on peut vivre avec 1200
euros enfin qu'ils essayent donc il faut
améliorer le financement il faut régler
par exemple les questions d'égalité
salariales entre les femmes et les
hommes durant la carrière parce que ça
des incident sur les pensions donc il y
a des solutions mais c'est des choix des
choix politiques qu'il faut faire bon
avant la retraite il y a le travail il
se trouve que la moitié des Français
considèrent que leur travail n'est pas
reconnu ni récompenser à sa juste valeur
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit Philippe
Martinez du rapport qu'entretienne les
Français avec leur boulot alors le
travail c'est un vaste un vaste sujet
que la CGT trade depuis des années des
années puisqu'on s'appelle tout le monde
le sait pas encore Confédération
générale du travail pas des travailleurs
ou des travailleurs du travail
la ça ça signifie que le premièrement le
travail
j'abord les questions de salaire
reconnaissance des califes mais le
travail en lui-même n'est pas reconnu
c'est à dire que de plus en plus on fait
on est confronté à du travail prescrit
c'est-à-dire une note de service qui
vous tombe de jeunes saison
par des managers qui ont certes des
compétences mais pas forcément dans le
domaine qui touche le le travailleur ou
la travailleuse et donc on vous oblige à
faire un boulot alors que celui qui doit
l'exécuter c'est que par expérience et
par qualification que ce qu'on lui
demande de faire c'est pas bien ça pose
la question donc de la de la de la
démocratie dans le sens large du terme
de comment on peut contester ou en tout
cas discuter des ordres ça c'est la
première chose et je crois que c'est ce
qu'on appelle le sens du travail
pourquoi je fais ce boulot pourquoi on
me demande de faire ce boulot pourquoi
on m'oblige à le faire comme ça et ça ça
nécessiterait un débat beaucoup plus
large que les réponses qu'on peut avoir
du monde politique quand on parle de
travail il vous répondent au chômage le
travail ça n'a rien à voir avec l'emploi
ou avec le chômage après il y a les
questions évidemment d'attractivité il y
a les questions liées à des phénomènes
politiques qu'on qualifie trop souvent
de phénomènes de société par exemple le
lien avec l'environnement et la
préservation de la planète il y a des
salariés notamment des jeunes qui
s'interrogent sur
l'impact de leur travail sur l'avenir de
la planète et je pense que c'est c'est
essentiel qu'il se pose ce genre de
questions donc c'est beaucoup plus vaste
que
quelques raccourcis que j'entends les
jeunes voudraient pu travailler ou que
uniquement
la crise de la covid et les conséquences
avec l'évolution du télétravail c'est
pas que ça le rapport au travail vous
voyez le travail comme une souffrance ou
comme un épanouissement c'est un peu
caricatural dit comme ça évidemment mais
le travail
devrait être en tout cas pour beaucoup
un épanouissement
il y a des métiers très difficiles où on
souffre on peut l'améliorer en justement
en travaillant sur les conditions de
travail mais je ne le travail c'est
d'abord du collectif c'est on bosse mais
ça aussi ça demande à revenir peut-être
un petit peu en arrière c'est les
discussions qu'on peut avoir à la
machine à café où on parle boulot mais
on parle sport culture c'est aussi les
temps de pause dans beaucoup
d'industries maintenant les ouvriers
n'ont plus de temps de pause pour manger
c'est un petit casse-croûte sur le coin
de la machine il faudra revenir à des
repas collectifs c'est du collectif le
travail c'est c'est l'échange et de plus
en plus on individualise le travail et
ça ça pose problème donc oui il y a des
métiers difficiles il faut régler par
les conditions de travail mais c'est pas
c'est pas que de la souffrance le
travail et puis la question de
rémunération fait partie niaise le
salaire évidemment les salaires sont-ils
trop en France et double question parce
que la question du salaire et de
l'inflation et je discutais avec le
numéro 2 du Medef qui me disait que
entre les hausses de salaire la
participation les primes en tout genre
et bien les salaires vont quasiment
progresser autant que l'inflation
mais beaucoup moins que les dividendes
versés aux actionnaires on a noté
ou les questions de se posent pas de la
même façon et c'est salarié des petites
boîtes il bossent et mais tout ce qu'ils
font c'est pour alimenter les
actionnaires du grand groupe comment
l'étranger dans les grands groupes dans
la multinationales étrangère parce
qu'elles sont de côté en bourse aussi
les mêmes questions se posent comment
est-ce qu'il gère ça mais il y a des
groupes français qui sont aussi
mondialisés d'ailleurs c'est ceux qui
font le plus de bénéfices il y a besoin
dans tous les groupes de revenir sur la
notion de répartition des richesses et
dans la répartition des richesses créées
il y a la question des salaires donc
et puis il faut partir des réalités
parce que moi j'en ai marre que des
milliardaires nous fassent la leçon sur
le fait que les salaires en France
soient trop enfin
ils ont qu'il a passé à vivre 6 mois
avec le SMIC ce qui se déplace en jetons
trois châteaux 18 résidences secondaires
et bah ils vivent trois mois au SMIC ils
vont faire leurs courses au lieu
d'envoyer des gens de du personnel de
maison comme on dit et puis ils vont ils
verront ce que c'est que la vraie vie de
millions de travailleurs de
travailleuses en faisant tous les
responsables mais il y a des inégalités
et tous les rapports d'ONG de
de de d'associations aux femmes
assorti cette semaine un rapport mondial
et en France des inégalités les
milliardaires sont de plus en plus
riches et les pauvres se sont de plus en
plus pauvres donc il y a
a besoin d'une autre répartition des
richesses dans le monde Philippe
Martignas qu'une boîte fasse des
bénéfices ça vous choque ou c'est normal
mais pas du tout mais pas du tout mais
ces signes de bonne santé mais investir
elle peut embaucher mais il faut qu'elle
le fasse il faut qu'elle le fasse or en
général et de plus en plus souvent les
bénéfices ça sert à alimenter je vous ai
donné des chiffres les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires les investissements il
y a quelques petits soucis
d'investissement mais faut que les
salariés soient actionnaires de
l'entreprise comme ça ça leur
reviendrait dans la poche oui mais le
système fait que quand ça donne mal à la
tête d'être actionnaires de sa boîte
parce que pour toucher des dividendes il
faut négocier sa suppression d'emplois
parce que l'évolution de la Bourse c'est
beaucoup de restructuration regardez à
chaque fois qu'il y a un plan de
restructuration l'action fait un bon en
avant important donc ouais c'est ça
donne mal à la tête d'être actionnaire
de sa boîte il faut négocier son
licenciement pour espérer voir son
action augmenter euh non il faut ça il
faut le revoir aussi la la la la la
mesure d'une d'une boîte efficace parce
que moi je préfère efficace que
compétitive c'est ces investissements
l'implication de ces salariés la
participation de ces salariés dans les
décisions ça ce serait une vraie mesure
de de d'efficacité d'une entreprise
gestion en Allemagne non c'est pas la
cause c'est pas pas besoin de lui donner
ce genre de qualificatif on peut co-géré
en favorisant les actionnaires il faut
qu'il y ait un réel poids des salariés
mais mais pas uniquement sur la
stratégie de l'entreprise y compris sur
leur travail et je vous ai expliqué que
trop souvent le travail subit et on n'a
pas assez la main sur son travail vous
avez la conviction que c'est dans le
rapport de force dans le bras de fer
qu'on décroche des avancées sociales en
faveur des salariés c'est pas la
conviction c'est l'expérience
dans tous les sens quand on veut
négocier et la dernière période le
montre nous écoute plus ou moins
poliment et puis à la fin on fait ce qui
était prévu avant de discuter donc il y
a toujours une phase de négociation mais
pourquoi
au bout de cette phase de négociation on
est toujours au même point qu'avant la
phase de négociation quand ça marche pas
on commence pas par le rapport de force
on commence toujours par la discussion
quand ça marche pas on finit par rapport
de force
et les syndicats ils ont toujours le
pouvoir d'influencer d'influer sur le
cours de l'histoire sociale de notre
pays où est-ce que c'est un peu une
époque révolue puisque je reviens l'idée
que les grèves les mobilisations de la
CGT on peut empêcher d'autres syndicats
la loi el khomri les ordonnances
Pénicaud la réforme ferroviaire les
premièrement les je le répète les
syndicats sans syndiqués il y a pas
assez de syndicat en France et sans
rapport avec le monde du travail ça ne
marche pas le syndicat c'est pas
nébuleuse comme ça ou un moustachu dans
son bureau c'est c'est des des hommes
des femmes qui discutent qui décident
qu'on des liens avec leurs collègues et
qui propose des choses et puis le monde
le monde il a changé le monde il a
changé il y a de plus en plus de choses
qui se règle à l'entreprise et c'est pas
un bien parce que sur des grands sujets
tels que vous les avez évoqués les gens
se disent c'est ça se décide au Conseil
des ministres des gens qu'on connaît pas
qui ont partagé pas la même vie donc
mais il y a eu beaucoup de luttes en
2022 il y en aura encore beaucoup en
2023 sur la question des salaires par
exemple ou les salariés sont mobilisés
ils ont obtenu des choses il y a pas
assez de s'indiquer dites-vous en France
qu'une réalité quelle part encore une
fois de responsabilité on les syndicats
là-dessus et comment inverser la
tendance à les choses ils ont pas
c'est pas de leur seul responsabilité
puisque il y a de la répression
syndicale et je pourrais vous citer des
tas d'exemples ou quand on fait grève
alors que c'est un droit constitutionnel
on risque de se faire licencier
mais pour ce qui concerne la
responsabilité des syndicats et de la
CGT que je connais un peu c'est le
besoin d'avoir un syndicalisme qui est
en phase avec le monde du travail tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui pas qui cautionne
les mauvaises évolutions du monde du
travail parce que oui on est contre le
travail du dimanche on est contre la
précarité on est contre l'ubérisation
c'est à dire des gens sans contrat pour
autant ce sont des travailleurs et des
travailleurs donc c'est pas parce qu'on
est contre la forme
d'exploitation qu'il subisse qu'il faut
pas s'occuper d'eux et ça on a besoin de
faire des progrès et de façon urgente
Philippe Martinez vous avez passé la
main cette année vous êtes secrétaire
général depuis 2015
qu'avez-vous appris pendant ces 8 ans la
tête de la CGT
qu'est-ce que
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur la
diversité du monde du travail ce que
j'ai fait beaucoup de déplacements je
vais beaucoup dans les entreprises dans
les services et j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses sur la diversité du monde du
travail des conditions de travail
dans les hôpitaux les EHPAD par exemple
mais dans d'autres entreprises dans
d'autres dans l'industrie etc donc ce en
fait c'est les salariés que j'ai croisé
qui m'ont appris beaucoup de choses
et puis j'ai appris aussi
peut-être encore plus que quand on est
responsable syndical mais je pense que
c'est valable encore plus pour les
responsables politiques faut être humble
l'humilité c'est pas un défaut c'est une
qualité c'est pas la version la mieux
partagée c'est oui oui notamment à
l'Elysée par exemple
oui il faut être humble faut savoir
écouter faut savoir écouter essayer de
comprendre pas arriver avec un discours
tout fait et puis expliquer aux gens
comment ça va se passer comment ça se
passe pour eux non faut écouter d'abord
et après essayer de trouver des
solutions ça c'est quelque chose une
expérience enfin plusieurs expériences
qui m'ont apporté voilà je veux pas
jouer les vieux machin mais c'est
quelque chose qui est essentiel ce dont
vous êtes le plus fier au terme de ce
mandat ce double mandat à la tête de la
CGT une action une décision une j'ai pas
de voilà j'ai pas un tableau d'honneur
dans mon bureau je pense que
j'ai essayé d'impulser un certain nombre
de choses
par exemple d'avoir été parmi les
premiers à mettre en place une cellule
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles dans la CGT et et par rapport
à des femmes qui côtoient la CGT c'était
bien avant MiTo je pense que
c'était avant-gardiste et je suis assez
fier de ça même si on rencontre des
difficultés comme partout pour
casser un peu les pattes du patriarcat
et du machisme est-ce que vous regrettez
après il y a plein de choses que je
regrette parce que il y a des tas de
chantier qui sont ouverts de pas avoir
encore une CGT
structurée pour accueillir toute la
diversité du monde du travail il y a
encore trop de travailleurs et de
travailleuses qui aimeraient venir à la
CGT et qui ne trouve pas encore très
bien leur place chez nous c'était une
vocation d'ailleurs de devenir
secrétaire général de la CGT ou ça vous
êtes tombé dessus à quel moment tiens on
se décide on se dit tiens ben je regarde
syndicaliste je veux être syndicaliste
c'est pas un métier c'est voilà on se
syndique c'est une activité militante
parce que et
en tout cas beaucoup de de syndiquer que
je croise
ce sont syndiqués parce qu'ils ont été
victimes d'une injustice c'est pas un
truc qu'on rêve dans son berceau c'est
quel injustice l'injustice c'est la
non-application d'une clause d'un accord
d'entreprise chez Renault qui a un jour
on m'a dit on avait une clause qui il y
a longtemps déjà fait que quand on
parlait une langue étrangère bien on a
on avait un examen on était noté en
fonction de cette note on avait une
prime et bien pour moi ça ne marchait
pas donc bah j'ai dit pourquoi ça ne
marche pas parce que c'est comme ça donc
j'ai été voir le syndicat voilà donc
c'est beaucoup de gens se syndiquent
parce qu'ils sont victimes de
l'injustices et on menait pas avec
l'ambiance c'est pas c'est pas un
parcours professionnel d'être
syndicaliste et d'avoir des
responsabilités c'est parfois des
concours de circonstances souvent parce
que
vos petits camarades disent ah tiens tu
accepterais de prendre cette
responsabilité vous savez c'est pas
on rêve pas ça dans son berceau en se
rasant tous les jours devant la glace
quand j'étais môme lesquels footballeur
professionnel
en tant que 10
à voir la carrière de Zidane c'est ça
fait rêver beaucoup de monde même si
c'était la génération d'après moi
c'était plutôt platiné mon héros il a
pas été champion du monde et oui on va
le voir en fait le meilleur sensation
avant de devenir numéro 1 de la CGT
est-ce que vous aviez un modèle ou un
anti-model de leaders syndical pas du
tout non non j'ai eu des bonnes
relations avec comme vous dites quelques
leaders de la CGT enfin j'en ai connu
quelques-uns je gardais derrière des
relations avec eux mais
pas il y a pas de modèle il y a
des choses qui vous inspirent ou des
choses que vous voulez continuer que des
prédécesseurs ont commencé mais pas
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous
inspirez ce qu'on fait parce que je les
ai principalement connu Louis Vianney
et Bernard Thibault qu'on impulsait
justement ce besoin de d'une CGT qui est
plus ouverte à la diversité du monde du
travail je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose qui s'est construit dans le temps
mais il y a encore du boulot comme je
vous ai dit la CGT perçue peut-être à
tort comme le syndicat qui dit non
est-ce qu'il y a pas de CGT l'une au
niveau national qui s'oppose et une CGT
dans les entreprises ou dans les
branches dans les entreprises qui
signent des accords il y a pas une doute
de CGT non mais ça c'est ça c'est des
caricatures ça c'est des caricatures
qu'on aime entretenir et quand on est un
peu objectif
c'est pas c'est pas le cas on reproche
toujours
la CGT la politique de la chaise vide
si on prend cette séquence du de la
réforme des retraites
on a participé à toutes les
concertations et pourtant j'ai encore
j'entends encore des commentateurs
avisés qui parlent d'une CGT qui a fait
la politique de la Suède vide concernant
la réforme des retraites la CGTL dit non
quand ça va pas mais à chaque fois
qu'elle dit non elle propose autre chose
le problème c'est qu'il faudrait qu'on
soit globalement plus objectif dans tous
ceux qui aiment commenter les fesses et
gestes de la CGT pour parler et de ce
que la CGT contest mais aussi de ce que
la CGT propose Philippe Martinez c'est
sous votre air que la CGT a perdu son
titre de premier syndicat de France au
profit de la CFDT là encore une fois
c'est quelle part de responsabilité ou
pas évidemment le premier a toujours une
part de responsabilité c'est comme un
entraîneur
dans une équipe de foot mais on peut pas
dire quand on gagne c'est les joueurs
qui ont gagné et quand on perd c'est de
la faute de l'entraîneur
je vous ai dit cette baisse d'audience
de la CGT elle date d'avant moi parce
que la mesure de la représentativité ça
fait peu de temps qu'on l'a sous cette
forme là et puis tout ce que je vous ai
dit qu'on commençait mes prédécesseurs
c'est d'avoir une CGT plus en face avec
la diversité du monde du travail
on est un peu à la bourre et donc faut
accélérer il y a des tas de gens dans
les entreprises d'ailleurs qui parfois
se défendent sans nous crise des gilets
jaunes d'autres choses de ce style quand
on connaît pas les syndicats quand on
les voit jamais on se dit ça sert à rien
or notre implantation n'est pas
suffisante pour qu'on ait une mesure
pour qu'on ait une représentativité qui
nous permettent de reconquérir notre
première place il y a un écart
d'implantation dans les entreprises
entre la CFDT et nous on est largement
en retard par rapport à la CFDT donc là
il y a du boulot si vous voulez on fait
une course on fait une course mais pour
arriver devant eux on part 20 mètres ou
40 mètres après eux donc faut courir
très vite et on court pas encore assez
vite fait Martinez vous avez croisé de
multiples reprises François Hollande et
Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce qu'il est
distingue et avec lequel vous avez eu le
plus d'affinités
souvent Emmanuel Macron en tête-à-tête
une fois en 5 ans et demi et François
Hollande deux fois c'est sur une période
plus courte je l'avoue c'était sur deux
ans enfin un an et demi
ils ont tous les deux
eu des mesures vis-à-vis du monde du
travail qui nous conduisent dans une
situation compliquée que ce soit vous
l'avez rappelé la loi el khomri
mais aussi on en parle beaucoup dans la
période les mesures de la réforme
Touraine
Emmanuel Macron a continué mais je vous
rappelle qu'il a été ministre de
François Hollande et paraît-il elle a
beaucoup inspiré les dernières lois
régressives mais à continuer en
accélérant
je pense que globalement peut-être
encore plus Emmanuel Macron françois
Hollande
connaît pas la réalité du monde du
travail il connaît il sait pas ils
savent pas enfin lui ne sait pas ce que
c'est que la vraie vie et je vous l'ai
dit l'humilité c'est pas un défaut c'est
une qualité et lui manque beaucoup
d'humilité la vraie vie va continuer
pour Philippe Martinet c'est quoi la
suite vous aurez 62 ans cette année
d'ailleurs pas sûr que vous puissiez
prendre votre retraite si le
gouvernement fait passer sa loi d'air
c'était pour ça que vous êtes devant
debout contre cette réforme ça n'a rien
à voir premièrement parce que j'adore
les taquins mais je suis taquin aussi
premièrement ce que vous auriez dû
étudier cette réforme et comme je suis
né dans le premier semestre 1961 et je
ne suis pas concerné par cette réforme
mais comme je suis comme les autres vous
savez qu'il y a l'âge
et le nombre de trimestres et bah il
m'en manque quelques-uns encore donc il
me reste à peu près un an à bosser donc
je suis payé par mon entreprise qui est
Renault donc vous retournez travailler
je vais retourner essayer de travailler
chez Renault parce que moi j'ai des
idées mais mes idées ne correspondent
pas encore tout à fait avec celle de la
direction de mon entreprise donc on va
négocier il est bien le cas des Méo non
le patron de Renaud je sais pas dans
quel sens vous dites il est bien il est
à l'écoute il est humble il est il
allait vertus qui vous plaisent à
l'écoute je de ces actionnaires c'est un
classique pour le PDG d'un grand groupe
il veut casser l'entreprise en deux vous
le savez une partie électrique et
électrique une partie terminée ce qui va
d'ailleurs pour moi et pour un certain
nombre de mes collègues changer mon
contrat de travail sans me demander mon
avis donc je sais pas s'il est très à
l'écoute finalement
bon une femme va se quitter là-dessus à
la tête de la CGT vous en rêvez vous est
proposé Marie buisson pour vous succéder
est-ce que ce rêve va devenir réalité
parce que c'est pas fait
c'est vraiment pas un rêve c'est je vous
ai expliqué c'est le sens de l'histoire
pendant plusieurs minutes que il fallait
que la CGT soit dans son monde
or vous le savez sur cette planète plus
d'un être humain sur deux est une femme
vous le saviez
52% et et donc il serait temps me
semble-t-il que dans la plus vieille
organisation syndicale de France qui va
avoir 128 ans cette année pour la
première fois depuis qu'elle existe et
bien en soi en phase avec le monde tel
qu'il est vous voyez je suis cohérent
dans dans mes pensées et et dans ma
volonté de voir une CGT toujours en
phase avec le monde du travail tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui merci Philippe Martinez
pour ce le sens merci à vous ça fut un
plaisir je rappelle que vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la CGT libre
échange c'est fini et c'est à revoir sur
Public Sénat il y a du replay bien sûr
sur public sénat.fr à bientôt
[Musique]